[Música]
miles de argentinos salieron a
manifestarse contra el gobierno nacional
la agrupaciones de izquierda ciudadanos
auto convocados y partidos opositores
protestaron bajo diferentes consignas
entre ellas el rechazo el acuerdo con el
fmi
llegará a las elecciones presidenciales
de octubre en Brasil los candidatos más
fuertes Yair bolsonaro y Luis Ignacio
lulada Silva llevaron sus mensajes a sus
seguidores en Sao Paulo y los pacientes
con cáncer en Perú enfrentan una
deficiencia de atención las enfermedades
neoplásicas son la segunda causa de
muerte en este país según cifras
oficiales 70.000 nuevos casos se
registran cada año
Hola Muy Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de Franz 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano si Santiago aristía
y comenzamos en Argentina en el marco de
la celebraciones por el día de la
independencia miles de ciudadanos
salieron a las calles para manifestarse
contra el gobierno nacional la
agrupación es de izquierda ciudadanos
auto convocados y partidos opositores
protestaron contra el gobierno de
Alberto Fernández el movimiento
socialista de los trabajadores centró
sus reclamos contra el acuerdo contra el
fondo monetario internacional las
manifestaciones se dan en medio de una
delicada situación económica con la
deuda externa en el centro de la
polémica algunos analistas señalan la
importancia de un actor en esta deuda
hablamos en concreto de Estados Unidos y
sus políticas regionales
es un problema que Argentina lleva
arrastrando desde hace décadas la deuda
externa Y si bien las causas son
diversas los analistas señalan la
importancia de un actor en concreto
Estados Unidos y sus políticas
regionales la trampa de la deuda la que
están sometidas desde hace década de los
países latinoamericanos tienen como
principal responsable a los Estados
Unidos los mecanismos financieros y de
endeudamientos para mantener sometidos a
los gobiernos de nuestros países a
llevar adelante políticas que beneficien
los negocios de las empresas
estadounidenses con la crisis económica
de finales de los 70 Argentina pidió
préstamos a acreedores internacionales
especialmente a bancos estadounidenses
también conocidos Como fondos buitre Y
aunque el tipo de interés era casi nulo
al principio Estados Unidos endureció
sus políticas monetarias con el tiempo
algo que hizo la deuda insostenible
devaluó la moneda nacional y aumentó su
dependencia
estamos absolutamente decididos a
cumplir con nuestras obligaciones y
apagar la deuda pero para poder pagar la
deuda Tenemos que trabajar y mucho tras
años de lucha la deuda ha ido subiendo
cada vez más recientemente la pandemia
de Kobe 19 aumentó los tipos de interés
agravando la crisis económica en la
región y obligando a Argentina a usar
sus nuevos préstamos para pagar las
deudas anteriores el objetivo primario
de Estados Unidos no es que Argentina
soluciones sus problemas sino más bien
una cuestión geopolítica y por otro lado
El poder mantener cierto control que ha
tenido históricamente Estados Unidos
sobre latinoamérica un tema por el que
los argentinos llevan manifestándose
desde los 80 defienden que su bienestar
es más importante que pagar una deuda y
a menos de 100 días de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil los aspirantes
más fuertes al palacio de hablamos por
supuesto de Yair bolsonaro y Luis
Ignacio lulada Silva movilizaron a miles
de simpatizantes en Sao Paulo mientras
que en Brasilia cientos de personas
exigieron el libre porte de armas
muestra de músculo en el escenario
electoral más importante de Brasil el
presidente Yahir bolsonaro y el
candidato Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
presidieron sendas movilizaciones en Sao
Paulo ambos con visiones diferentes pero
la estrategia similares bolsonaro entre
grupos evangélicos llamó a la lucha del
bien contra el mal también se refirió a
uno de los temas de actualidad el aborto
[Música]
Este es un país que defiende la vida
desde la concepción es un país que aboga
por el respeto a los niños en las aulas
y por eso está en contra de la ideología
de género
[Música]
entre tanto Lula que califica su campaña
como la lucha del amor contra el odio
arremetió contra el mandatario
ultraderechista el también ex presidenta
acusó la actual jefe de estado de
promover el hambre en el gigante
suramericano vine a Sao Paulo por el
hambre 70 años después y después de que
el PT acabara con el hambre en el país
ahora 33 millones de brasileños se van a
dormir sin tener que comer Cómo se
explica esto en un país que es el tercer
mayor productor de alimentos del mundo
85 días del proceso electoral las
encuestas no favorecen a bolsonaro
Presenta una desventaja entre 15 y 20
puntos ante su adversario mientras ambos
líderes aseguraban apoyos en Sao Paulo
en Brasilia la capital cientos de
personas marcharon al congreso para
exigir el libre aporte de armas según
los manifestantes la marcha apoyaba el
derecho a la autodefensa y a la
seguridad
Mientras tanto siguen aumentando las
cifras de deforestación de la amazonía
brasileña que en el primer semestre del
año batió un nuevo
récord con casi 4.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de vegetación arrasada el
informes de Marina sardinia
otro trágico récord para la degradación
de la amazonía brasileña en el primer
semestre de 2022 la deforestación arrasó
con 3.988 kilómetros cuadrados de selva
un 10,6% más que el mismo periodo del
año anterior según los datos del propio
gobierno de Brasil
esto es muy malo el primer semestre en
el Amazonas es cuando tenemos la
temporada de lluvias por lo que no
deberíamos estar viendo estos números
tan altos por lo que tenemos una
combinación de un clima más seco con más
motivación para deforestar
la vegetación de la selva tropical más
grande del Mundo queda reducida a tierra
y madera para su venta grandes
extensiones que serán empleadas
principalmente para la ganadería y los
macrocultivos desde la llegada del Ultra
derechista Yair bolsonaro al poder las
cifras de deforestación se han
incrementado ante la falta de controles
gubernamentales y de políticas públicas
para frenar las actividades ilícitas que
conlleva la deforestación beneficios
cochinista Pues los próximos meses es
difícil ser optimista para los próximos
meses en la amazonía sabemos incluso por
estudios académicos que en año electoral
tenemos un aumento de la deforestación
por lo que se ha deforestado en este
primer semestre es muy posible que
también haya muchos incendios durante el
verano amazónico la estación más seca
si bien esta problemática preocupa más
fuera que dentro de Brasil con una larga
tradición de deforestación potenciada
desde las mismas instituciones en los
años 80 y una carencia de conciencia
medioambiental los ambientalistas
confían que sea un tema de campaña de
Cara a los comicios de octubre y Perú se
enfrenta a una deficiencia de atención
de los pacientes con cáncer recordemos
que las enfermedades neoplásicas son la
segunda causa de muerte en este país el
informe es de Francisco Zacarías
corresponsal de Franz 24 en Lima
Amanda Quispe vive un múltiple drama su
hijo tiene cáncer y no recibió
tratamiento oportuno ahora sufre
convulsiones ha perdido a la vista y la
memoria como el sistema sanitario
Estatal quedó saturado Amanda lo internó
en una clínica para salvar su vida hoy
debe más de 127 mil dólares y les dan
por embargar la casa sentimos que somos
discriminados no sentimos que hemos
discriminados no somos escuchados y así
como mi niño Hay un montón de niños y
hay otros que ya no están con nosotros
no han partido ya han fallecido por por
esta mala atención también en Perú las
enfermedades neoplásicas son la segunda
causa de muerte en el país según cifras
oficiales 70.000 nuevos casos se
registran cada año en el mismo periodo
35.000 peruanos han fallecido por cáncer
la defensoría del pueblo denuncia
escasez de medicamentos y demoras en
tratamientos y cirugías Alejandro
Escobar paciente con cáncer de próstata
demanda una buena atención en salud sí
quisiera que hagan por lo menos unos
tres hospitales iguales para poder
conservar a todos nuestros hermanos
que estamos mal
Dios quiera
que antes que me muera
el Ministerio de salud reconoce
deficiencias en atención debido a la
pandemia del Coby 19 el gobierno ha
dispuesto presupuesto para mejorar los
servicios oncológicos sin embargo no
habrá solución a la crisis en el corto
plazo nos va a tomar aproximadamente 7 8
años para poder llegar a los estadios
precobit recién en el año 2030 podremos
predecir que estamos llegando a los
escenarios pre pandemia Amanda Quispe
también exige que las autoridades
atiendan su reclamos para evitar la
muerte de su hijo en Perú
175.000 personas esperan la
implementación de la ley Nacional del
cáncer que garantiza cobertura universal
y oportuna
y finalizamos en bolivianas donde se
combinan dos elementos que atraen las
miradas de todo el mundo automóviles y
hermosos paisajes los fanáticos del
modelo Beatles de Volkswagen viajaron en
caravana por las carreteras de la
Cordillera real para conmemorar el
aniversario de la producción del último
beetler en 2019 cerca de una decena de
propietarios de este clásico y su
familia participaron en la actividad con
estas imágenes Nos despedimos sigan en
France 24
[Música]